mientras los incendios en el pantanal
brasileño alcanzan dimensiones
históricas pues sonaron dice que no hay
en el mundo otro país que se muere más
por cuidar su entorno como el suyo
enardeciendo los ánimos en brásil que
alberga el 60 por ciento del mayor
humedal del planeta un patrimonio que
comparte con paraguay y bolivia y que ha
visto el 16 por ciento del área quemada
solo en su territorio aunque algunas ong
calculan que la destrucción supera el
20% del ecosistema
brasil es el país que más preserva el
medio ambiente algunos no lo entienden
porque es el país que más sufre ataques
del extranjero por el medio ambiente
las cifras sin embargo lo contradicen
sólo este septiembre los incendios del
pantanal brasileño hicieron historia los
5 mil 603 focos de calor detectados en
los primeros 16 días del mes han
superado con creces los 2 mil 887 del
2019 y están por dejar atrás los 5 mil
993 registrados en 2005 el peor año
hasta ahora para este humedal los
detractores le piden a bolsonaro y
asumir
intro defensa a asumir la
responsabilidad política es fundamental
movilizar recursos y personal para
apagar el fuego en el pantanal cerrado o
la amazonía
bolsonaro y salles deben responder
penalmente por la tragedia
el instituto ese o ese pantanal calcula
que más del 90 por ciento de los
incendios este año fueron provocados por
ganaderos y hacendados que hacen quemas
para ampliar sus tierras para la
ganadería
bolsonaro lo acusan de promover estas
actividades y aunque la policía federal
ya comenzó operaciones para identificar
a los culpables más de 1.200 especies y
un vasto bioma están en riesgo y las
pérdidas según los ecologistas serían
incalculables